from Michael Rionda the director of work
and everybody dies in 90 seconds
what are those movies
I don't know and Jeff Roe the director
of doesn't look like he's directed
anything else from the studio that
brought you spider-man into the
spider-verse connected if you're a part
of the states that qualify for Super
Tuesday make sure to vote today I'm not
gonna tell you who to vote for just
freakin vote keep politics out of your
video even though this general statement
you can make about just encouraging
people to vote is your civic duty
especially all the kids who are watching
this trip yes 13 and none if you're at a
school that allows you to vote for Tizen
leave class and go vote to you
[Music]
that's a trailer for a trailer he used
to be my little buddy in the meantime I
made you guys this divider yes you know
what this is our last night together
oh no he's exactly why I'm excited to
meet a lady
that's mean so you can buy her a new
computer
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport I canceled your plane ticket
to college hey drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
voice it's Danny McBride is it this took
a major left sir
nap does happen to me
it's a Bruce Almighty shot yeah oh it's
funny is this an original concept we're
not interested now not around where's
where the the plot points I recognize
from previous films Phil Lord and Chris
Miller have done it again that's right
only they have done it yeah you know
it's weird about this trailer hmm life
flashed to two movies I don't think
anyone else will flash to but it's what
this guy thought of Raging Bull I
thought it from dusk till dawn and I
thought of at Worlds and from the
Cornetto trilogy you guys haven't seen
that some wonderful film it really looks
like first half is one completely
different film and in the last half will
be a total sidebar do something
completely fictional a fantastical but
I'd like it in more to at worlds and
because this is a family they're growing
apart like the father/daughter dynamic
is somehow always resonates with me you
know being a young girl growing up with
my father and now with your daughter
yeah exactly it's really rough the
family dynamics and because it's about
like a father wanting to connect with
his daughter he's having a hard time
letting her go but there's also like
subtle foreshadowing in this trailer
with how he disagrees with how the youth
handle technology talking about the
cellphones and like put your phone away
the laptop yeah all those things that
you could be more in the moment little
hints at his disagreement with
technology and then suddenly it takes us
complete shift into crazy AI attacking
what's gonna bring them together
ultimately in the end is them having to
fight against this enemy so that's where
I liking it a little bit more to a film
like at World's End where it seems like
this came out of nowhere but really when
you watch it like oh no there's little
hints throughout I don't know if like
the AI thing will come in like twenty
five minutes into the movie or something
but it looks like it's coming in like
halfway through yeah yeah it's like it's
gonna start out as an actual and
probably fanciful but affecting animated
movie that then takes a sci-fi turn or
something and I kind of hope it does
that me I was really getting into the
first half of the trail it felt like a
Pixar movie or something circa that new
style that they've got going that's very
like a smash of 3d and 2d animation like
I like that Sony Pictures animation
has been able to establish at least what
I think is a very vivid and a very
distinct but also a very appealing
visual style hmm
cuz spider-verse introduced that and
this isn't as extreme with the
comic-book embellishments and the making
it look like print or stop-motion but
there is a quality of that and I was
noticing especially in a lot of those
shots where they're in the kitchen
together it looks like a piece of
hand-drawn artwork especially on the
shading and stuff like that what they've
been able to do with that design of
their people their characters and stuff
it's very distinct and very appealing in
a way I feel like I haven't noticed from
another studio in a long time well no
the way the the animation looks here
seems less like something out of lego
movie or spider-verse and not exactly
Pixar it feels a little bit more like
the Disney computer animated movies we
get lately something closer like big
hero 6 yeah that kind of animation style
you know having someone like Maya
Rudolph here voicing and Danny McBride
voicing I like that choice because like
a Family Guy for example they're kind of
humor that often makes it funny is
watching animated characters interact in
a very human way and I think when you
have people like Danny McBride who have
that kind of comic sensibility where the
kind of argumentative type of behavior
debating kind of behavior whatever
banter the banter comes in the form of
the Hat like this feels like something
you'd hear argue about in real life I
think is appropriate for having his
voice here because when you're Danny
McBride you know you so ciated with a
very specific type of personality so
this is the only way I can see him being
a father
Herbies it's kind of character is it an
animated format he actually kind of
blends in there because you do spend the
first couple of minutes going wait a
minute who is that maybe we'll get a
surprisingly nuanced and like Danny
McBride can definitely act but this
almost feels more subtle in an
environment where I would expect him to
get way more big well yeah I appreciate
all joking aside from the intro these
directors and writers they have a lot of
work and television they worked on
gravity falls and disenchantment which
are our two shows that have its fan base
people like them it is I personally
haven't seen them but gravity falls is
an especially big one I think Sony
Pictures out of all the studios that
seems to be trying to compete with the
animation department with lightened is
the Saudi seems to be the only one that
really has a good chance it's like yes
there's people like Lika which are
really respected you know like critics
really love them audiences love them but
they don't really bring in the box
office numbers just like Golden Globe
and then you have like illumination
Studios who tends to make animated films
that you know make a lot of money but
people they're not as beloved yeah I was
respected and I think of what they've
been doing with Sony especially with
having people like Lorde and Miller
be creative producers involved they seem
to be a real competition for people for
the folks over at Disney as well so this
is this looks really awesome yeah one
occupies a space that I think is nice
with animated movies it kind of reminded
me also a ParaNorman in the sense that
that is a kid accessible movie but that
doesn't feel like a kids movie this gave
me that same vibe because it seems like
we're gonna look at the dad as a
character just as much as the daughter
as a character and it's gonna be an
actual like family story cuz ParaNorman
also has that quality of its a
dysfunctional family learning to accept
each other and to connect better if it
all goes well would hopefully be very
engaging and fun for kids but also have
a lot of rich storytelling for adults
the similar way like the lego movie did
I feel like spider-verse achieves that
too I feel like if there's one thing
that we can associate with you know the
people who Lord Miller then collaborate
with it yeah it's that I'm kind of
wondering why it's specifically called
connected because what I like about what
this trailer communicates and what I
feel like the movie will do there are
leading a with the characters and
leading with the heart because it could
have been easy to just do a movie that's
only about this AI sci-fi take over
scenario right like and I usually would
probably expect other movies so just
lead only with that and then you get
this story like as afterthought in the
beat yeah the first parts of this
trailer like the dad just seemed so
disconnected from technology like even
the the camera that they have on the
road trip is you're watching the camera
footage in the beginning and it's like
an old-school camera and then when
they're on the road trip it's still an
old-school camera it's not like an
updated high-tech device so maybe the
daughter in the end will use some of her
technological knowledge to help defeat
some of this AI stuff I wonder if like
the connected thing could have a double
meaning oh yeah
like beyond just the family dynamic
could it be part of our relationship
with technology because I feel like this
movie will probably go out of its way to
have some type of commentary maybe even
in a subtle way maybe not really on the
nose but something that can help kids be
a little bit more aware like a big
conversation that I'm always hearing
about kids are more disconnected
nowadays and because of the fact that
they're so glued to their iPads and
their phones and stuff and he held even
adults are so maybe this is gonna be
something that comets just a little bit
on that alright guys what do you think
of the connected trailer are you excited
for it leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the reject nation click the
notification well let's end this with us
Katie Ann I was messaging you and
apparently missed your birthday so we're
gonna make it up to you right now
John sing happy birthday to her Katie
Ann happy non-copyright birthday to you
happy non-copyright birthday to you
happy non-copyright birthday dear Katie
Ann happy non-copyright birthday to you
and belated and belated also yeah cuz
it's late